Hey, happy birthday! I
kept it a secret because I wanted to surprise you. Even
though everyone was busy, you took the trouble to get together and prepare. It seems like it was a
great success. The cute princess is
surprised.
Thank
you.  Oh, that's terrible. I made the princess cry. That's how
happy I am. You
have an ugly crying face. It's unnecessary.
Now, let's eat. Let's
celebrate Nefertima's rapid growth and make a toast. Nema-chan,
come here. This is Your Majesty.  Congratulations from me
[Music] A
necklace made of demons I've put some powerful magic into it.
To use it, you need a
certain spell. It's called Uncle Gardi.
Oh, what's so stupid about that?  That's what
I'm saying.Father, this is what I'm saying.Dad, unlike my mother's, it's a
charm, so keep it on your skin.It's
like saying the previous one is useless.I'm saying that it's your
clothes.  Hats and shoes, I've
devised a way to cut them even when I grow up, so I
trust a wise man who created an encyclopedia of flora from all continents.Here's a
hair ornament made from the scales of a tree.  You
let me take it without any hesitation.The next time I see it, I'll stroke the scales in the place I don't want touched the most.I
call this child Rainhawk, a member of the Greyhawk family.He was born on an earthen tree.  He is the smartest and most powerful of the children.
This small, fluffy baby has
been raised on the assumption that he will be bought at the mansion, and he
has received his parents' permission.
The other day, even a heavy equipment worker
was watching Greyhawk with great enthusiasm.  I guess
Greyhawk is still big right now, so
please take care of this Rainhawk
[Music] Please
[Music]
Thank you everyone, I wish you the best birthday.